that's why I'm saying like Islam
provides a man that outlet to exercise
his pilliginous nature if he so wishes
to only if he can provide obviously well
I mean yes there are there is something
called No Strings Nika which is where a
woman voluntarily forsakes some of her
rights if she finds herself in a
situation where she doesn't want a man
full-time let me give you an example
she's been married twice Thrice through
two or three times before she's a two
times baby mama of three or four kids
all right and she's got two boys at home
as well and they don't want to see next
man coming into the house yeah boys are
jealous over their mums as it is she's
got a full-time job she's caring for her
mum she's got these kids at home she
doesn't want a full-time husband but she
wants to be able to have experience the
perks of a marriage with a man on a
part-time basis what is she to do
because Islam prohibits Xena which is
sex outside of marriage right
fornication or adultery